bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france gilles casanova
que dit la mobilisation de ce jour est
ce qu'il vous semble y avoir une
homogénéité dans les revendications
qu'est ce qui rassemble l'ensemble de
ces protestataires
il y à un élément qu'on connaît depuis
maintenant quelques temps ce sont les 88
% de français qui considèrent que
ces mesures sanitaires ont atteint un
seuil relativement insupportable et donc
là on à la base de la mobilisation on a
par ailleurs toujours le vieux terreau
des gilets jaunes c'est à dire d'une
protestation
global
sur la question du prix de l'essence sur
la question de du pouvoir d'achat sur
une série de questions concernant les
rapports de l'exécutif avec la
population et qui sont
un problème est qu'ils sont une
difficulté pour les gens donc on a là
une pointe de gens qui décident
d'agir de façon assez décidé alors à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans d'autres
pays
sur les mesures sanitaires mais qui en
fait rencontre un problème français quel
regard portez vous de votre côté 1 bruno
pomart sur ces
manifestations est ce que vous comprenez
la colère et les revendications des
protestataires
oui on peut entendre effectivement les
problématiques de notre pays depuis bien
longtemps d'ailleurs à ce n'est pas que
d'aujourd'hui mais je crois qu'encore
une fois ces manifestations sont en
train de s'éteindre on n'aura pas je
pense la résurgence mais je parle sous
le contrôle de du monsieur qui était
qu'elle intervient également avec moi
monsieur casanova on n'aura pas ce
retour des gis les journaux comme on a
pu le voir au tout début de set ce grand
mouvement donc c'est quand même quelque
chose qui a tendance à s'atténuer et
c'est tant mieux quelque part mais en
même temps il faudrait que le
gouvernement prenne en considération ces
revendications parce que quoique ça sera
nécessaire pour notre pays si on veut
gilles casanova sur les manifestants des
convois de la liberté quel est leur
profil est ce qu on a une idée aussi
peut-être de la composition politique du
mouvement
c'est la même que les gilet jaune c'est
à dire que ce sont des gens qui ne sont
pas des habitués de la politique ce sont
des gens qui ont été
révoltés ou ont été
mobilisés par des événements précis qui
se sont retrouvés qui se sont
rassemblées on le voit d'ailleurs quand
ces convois sont passés dans les villes
petites et moyennes de province ils ont
été très bien accueillis pas du tout de
la même façon que la capitale qui vit ça
de manière très névrotique avec une
terreur qui semblait s'être emparée des
autorités notamment dans le quartier des
champs elysées mais
ce qui est frappant c'est que de toute
façon comme les autorités contrairement
à l'habitude ou des partis politiques
sont au pouvoir là on a au pouvoir un
homme à peu près seul avec une majorité
de députés qui tous les six mois lui re
vote des pouvoirs spéciaux donc il n'a
absolument aucun compte à rendre à
personne et donc il est insensible aux
revendications insensible aux
manifestations contrairement à ce qu
était le cas des pouvoirs précédents qui
socialiste ou républicain quelle que
soit la forme partidaire qui était la
leur avait le souci de maintenir pour
tous les notables locaux régionaux et
nationaux de ce parti un certain
dialogue avec la population
l'exécutif actuel n'a de dialogue avec
la population qui à travers des
opérations qui sont plus proches du
monologue comme le grand débat par
exemple ou pour vous souvenez qu'un
préfet donne la parole à des personnes
qui l'a choisie pour poser des questions
qu'il a préparé avec elle
vous voyez ces images en direct de
l'avenue des champs elysées les forces
de l'ordre qui vraisemblablement en
tente de disperser les derniers
manifestants emmanuel macron appelé hier
au plus grand calme le chef de l'état
qui a déclaré entendre et respecter à la
fatigue et la colère liée à la crise
sanitaire je le cite sur le terrain
message de fermeté ce sont plus de 3000
forces de l'ordre qui ont été déployées
on a vu des images de blindés a mobilisé
ce que la réponse des autorités la bonne
à bruno pomart
écoutez je crois que la réponse et
laissez-les que le gouvernement avec le
mystérieux euro ont décidé de mettre en
place depuis d'ailleurs la veine ward et
des opérations gilet jaune vous savez
que on a été un moment donné la mission
intérieure était un peu débordé avec ces
opérations il ya maintenant deux ans et
de fait évidemment la préfecture de
police a travaillé effectivement à
remettre en forme ces nouvelles formes
de manifestations qui ne sont plus
celles que nous avons connues pendant
des décennies c'est à dire des
manifestations qui étaient encadrés par
les services d'ordre donc qui évite
évidemment les débordements comme on a
pu le voir tout au long de ces deux
années et je pense que la réaction du
préfet l'allemand effectivement et et
d'anticiper ces risques de violence en
mettant beaucoup de forces de l'ordre
présents gendarmerie des opc la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation avec les braves et toutes
les unités possible pour éviter que ces
groupuscules cristallise certains
secteurs de paris et de façon à ce que
on évite les dérapages je pense qu on le
voit même sur les champs-elysées vous
savez pas beaucoup de monde un
fectivement sap a été une manifestation
très très dur loin de là je pense que
les forces de l'ordre ont fait preuve de
pédagogie de discernement aussi c'est
pas toujours évident croyez moi parce
que parfois on a affaire à des individus
qui sont qui sont compliqués à gérer et
je pense que la typologie effectivement
je parle sous le contrôle monsieur
casanova était très différente on avait
les passes les antilles parce qu'ils
étaient présents avec plutôt quelques
petites mouvance de l'extrême gauche
d'après les informations comment donner
et puis sur les champs elysées des gens
qui venaient passer un moment je dirais
revendiquer évidemment leur liberté
c'est une chose mais on avait deux types
de deux typologies redire de personnes
présentées pour les forces de l'ordre
encore une fois je vous le disais entre
le xiiie arrondissement entre les champs
elysées entre denfert-rochereau et bien
les 7200 forces de l'ordre ont été
réparties de façon
stratégique pour éviter encore une fois
que les affrontements parce que
l'objectif c'est ça ce qu'il n'y ait pas
d'affrontement au bout du compte les
champs elysées qui semble clairsemée à
ce soir les forces de l'ordre sur le
pied de guerre pour
disperser les les tout derniers
protestataires à deux mois de la
présidentielle gilles casanova quel est
le rôle l'enjeu du scrutin à venir dans
cette contestation la candidate
socialiste anne hidalgo a invité ces
manifestants à s'exprimer en votant oui
elle a d'abord apporter tout son soutien
à la politique répressive des manuels
macron c'est la première partie tout de
même de son intervention ensuite leur a
signalé qu'ils peuvent toujours
s'exprimer par leur bulletin de vote on
voit là un problème qui est celui de la
crise de l'offre politique on voit bien
que l'offre politique telle qu'elle est
présentée il ne répond pas à l'attenté
d'une bonne partie de la population
vous voyez bien que lorsque dans les
mêmes sondages
on nous dit que les deux tiers des
français ne souhaitent pas que mad men
mâcon se représente et dans les mêmes
sondages on nous montre que quel que
soit l'opposant c'est lui qui
l'emportera on voit bien qu'il y a là
une distance entre l'offre politique et
la tante des français cette distance
elle est très dangereuse parce que elle
peut se concrétiser ensuite par des
manifestations et puis par des violences
parce que là nous sommes avant
l'élection présidentielle
il est très rare que des mouvements
sociaux aient lieu avant une élection
présidentielle compte tenu du fait que
les forces se concentrent autour de
cette élection mais justement là vous
voyez la gauche est quasiment absente de
cette élection la droite traditionnelle
à très grand mal à se mettre en position
d'être au second tour de cette élection
et nous ne voyons que des forces
original nouvelle disposant de peu de
force partidaire disposant d'un fort
écho dans la population un fort écho
médiatique mais qui n'est pas construit
autour de la façon dont la démocratie
s'est construite en france c'est à dire
les mairies les départements les régions
etc et dont vous voyez là qu'on est dans
une crise tout à fait consistante qui
est une crise de l'offre politique
les français ne sont pas satisfaits de
l'offre politique qu'ils ont et il le
manifeste
autrement que par un bulletin de vote
puisque c'est justement le bulletin de
vote qui pose problème il ne trouve pas
le bulletin qui leur convient ils sont
moins de 13% à se reconnaître dans une
formation politique ou un homme
politique un tout dernièrement assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien avec
vous bruno pomart que peuvent redouter
aujourd'hui vos collègues des forces de
l'ordre une contagion un mouvement
d'ampleur à l'image de celui d'un gilet
jaune
mais écoutez oui oui je pense que ça ne
se réalisera pas mais pour autant chez
qui mentent il faut éviter la contagion
donc est-ce qu'il faut rentrer dans le
dialogue avec le gouvernement
c'est une chose mais je pense que
effectivement les forces de l'ordre ne
souhaite qu'une seule chose c'est que ce
ne se renouvelle pas ce type de
manifestation encore une fois il faut
toutes proportions gardées
voir que évidemment ça n'a pas mobilisé
beaucoup de monde donc les risques de
contagion sont restées limitées je pense
que les gens sauront fatigue et aussi le
temps et cherche aussi pour certains
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui à
revendiquer quand même cette forme de
liberté que tout le monde a besoin
effectivement après ses deux ans passés
et cette pression évidemment de du coc
vider toutes les restrictions que nous
avons les heures et les autres ont subi
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cet échange ce soir bruno pomart on
sait policiers du raid et gilles
casanova expert en stratégie et
communication